[Musique]
d'abord parce que super les
ex-rebelles et belle équipe de merde
franck mali qu'on vient de voir ces
images complètement dingue de cette
avant première à marseille
alors comment vous l'avez vécu ce moment
que vous attendiez je suppose depuis
quand même plusieurs mois bon d'abord
avait été accueilli comme une rock star
c'était c'était assez incroyable ce qui
s'est passé à marseille on s'attendait
pas à ce qu'ils aient cette foule
s'attendait pas à ce qu'ils aient autant
de salles pleines du jamais vu moi dans
ma tête j'étais bono pendant 48 heures
là je suis en tournée et en tournée
voilà c'est un truc qu'on fantasme
toujours et vous savez quand on fantasme
quelque chose on est souvent déçu parce
que l'imaginaire travail on se dit ah
forcément je m'attendais pas à ça
j'imaginais ça et là même dans nos rêves
les plus fous vraiment viser saillard
avec franck
on n'aurait pas imaginé ce cet
engouement et force est de constater
qu'à des enfants de 7 ans comme les
grands parents qui sont avec eux 70 ans
hors assurance et un problème pourquoi
j'ai c'était important que ce soit à
marseille en premier taxi c'est merci
ses films des marseillais quand dany
boon fait faire un film sur le nord
évidemment que c'est là-bas qu'il est
présente en premier il fallait que le
film part de marseille
on les a fait galérer surtout on a fait
galérer les marseillais dire que on est
arrivé au début c'était très marrant
parce que tu vois il est marseillais
venir nous féliciter les trois quatre
premiers jours de tournage fraîchement
est fier très chemin merci de remettre
le taxi dans la ville parce que ça nous
a manqué et puis après au bout de quatre
semaines le discours il a changé quand
on leur bloquer les accès et venez nous
voir dit il pour combien de temps votre
film là en fait parce que ça commençait
trop lent et vous leur avez dit que vous
êtes fan du psg ou pas
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à vous mon reflet bercy
alors hier avant première parisienne au
grand rex
elle vous le disiez aussi sur scène un
rêve de gosse pour le coup autant
marseille c'est au delà de nos
espérances des paris à cette espèce de
truc un peu où là parfois c'est un peu
plus froid quoi cette salle il ya des
gens qui en ressortent traumatisé
parfois la comédie c'est un genre bien
particulier parce que ça va provoquer
des réactions immédiates sur le public
on écrit des vannes ça marche ça marche
pas les gens rigolent où il régale pas
on n'a pas besoin d'attendre la fin du
film pour savoir si c'est en train de
prendre au bout de quelques minutes
ça rigole et puis au bout d'un moment ça
applaudit en même temps que ça rigole
et là on se dit bon apparemment c'est en
fait en train de prendre
mais on est en train de le découvrir à
ce moment là c'est à dire qu'on se tient
comme ça à côté dans le siège on en
train de
on est en train de découvrir que ça
marche quoi on est en train de découvrir
que va peut-être qu'on a réussi ce film
[Musique]
c'est bon c'est parce qu'il est content
comment ça s'est passée l'écriture ce
que je sais que luc besson il vous
freinez un petit peu non mais lucky luke
il m'a appris quelque chose c'est être
capable de d'élargir mon humour d'être
capable de parler au plus grand nombre
sans dénaturer ce que j'aime
profondément c'est le mélange entre un
nouvelle génération les films dessous ce
que je fais moi et puis les termes elle
l'ultime respect de la saga taxi c'est
un taxi qui fait par des mecs qui sont
fans de taxi donc on ne pouvait que la
respecter le site il est bien en
préparation au moins dans votre tête
j'ai pris deux petites notes au chaos
que ça sera le sixième élément qu'on est
en train de bosser avec luc besson
chiquita la reprise de nikita voilà on
est sur pas mal de projets et j'ai un
petit questionnaire voiture pour vous si
vous étiez une voiture ce serait quoi
une volkswagen passat la voiture que mon
père a gardé 48 en voiture elle avait un
million quatre cent mille kilomètres
c'était la renault 25 vous savez on a
tous une voiture quand elle est partie à
la casse on est grand père dit quelqu'un
de notre famille et quand cette passat
jeu les u21 mon père l'a eue avant que
je naisse et il a lâché l'année dernière
vraiment c'était mou franck d'être un
petit peu plus nerveux n'en ouais mais
je suis obligé de te dire une 407 à une
407 en revanche la chanson ma réponse
est allé courir moi la chanson vous
écoutez en voiture
tu me plais karine et des secondes je
sais quel camp je peux la de la
ve-hotech j'ai pas mieux cela allait
super au bout de combien de fois vous
avez votre code alors bizarrement il
faudra qu'on m'explique je ne sais pas
comment je me suis débrouillé pour
permis et codes du premier choix du
premier fouet le baccalauréat la
quatrième fois bat france est 4 fois ses
origines tu peux faire ce que tu veux
c'est elle a beau gosse la coupe le
maquillage mais c'est mon père ça que
s'est vengé les entrants moi ce que je
me suis foutu de la gueule de sa passat
tu vois comme une scène d'anthologie
dans le film aliker un cache cache bien
sûr a je pense qu'on peut se quitter sur
une petite partie de cache cache avec
plaisir surtout vous en fait si je
devais me cachais faut pas qu'on me voit
alors du coup bah oui voila je suis
caché dans des caches les personnes te
vois personne parfaite
il est